hi
thank you for joining us today today
we'll be telling you about
what's new in network security on google
cloud my name is emil keiner
i'm a product manager on the cloud
networking team and i am joined by my
colleague tracy jang
also product manager on the team first
we're going to start by giving you a
brief overview of network security on
google cloud
from there i'll dive into cloud armor
and share all the latest and greatest
developments in the product
next tracy will take over and talk about
all of the new things with cloud
firewall and also share
about our new product offering around
packet mirroring
security follows a shared responsibility
model on google cloud
we work to secure our network and
infrastructure and provide customers the
tools necessary to do so as well in
their own projects
we enable and encourage customers to
follow a defense in-depth approach
and deploy security controls at various
levels of their stack and infrastructure
to enforce access controls and ensure
data and mission critical workloads
remain private and secure
on google cloud we have several key
network security controls
starting from the outside in we have
cloud armor the identitywear proxy and
the global load balancers as our layer 7
controls at the edge of the network
cloud armor in conjunction with the
global lbs protect applications from
ddos attacks
the iap is part of our beyond corp line
of products to allow access to internal
applications and workloads
without needing a vpn firewalls in red
apply at the vpc level and can be used
to customize
access for north-south traffic as well
as east-west traffic
into out of or through a bpc firewalls
are used to define vpc boundaries but
can be
as granular as per host vpc service
controls in blue
can be used to control access to and
from gcp
managed api services such as bigquery or
google cloud storage
to or from the internet into or out of
your vpcs or on-premise resources
in yellow we have our latest offering
packet mirroring
that allows you to deploy a tap and
mirror packets at the vm or container
cluster boundary to a configurable
collector destination
finally we also support sending outbound
traffic through cloudnet
to enhance privacy and security as well
as various internet
interconnect and vpn configuration
options
with cloud armor customers are able to
protect their applications from ddos
attacks
filter incoming requests by geography
or most layer 7 parameters like request
headers or cookies
moreover as a web application firewall
cloud armor contains pre-configured
rules to prevent
and mitigate the most common attacks and
vulnerability exploit attempts
users have access to real-time telemetry
in the form of
cloud logs containing cloud armor's
decisions on a per-request basis
as well as a real-time monitoring
dashboard that gives granular views of
allowed denied and previewed traffic
with google cloud armor customers
applications and websites are protected
with an
unrivaled level ddos protection as well
as a web application firewall able to
satisfy
internal security policies as well as
external regulatory regimes
the ddos protection cloud customers
receive is the same that has been
developed over the past 20 years
to help protect and ensure the
availability of google's own
services in conjunction with the global
load balancing infrastructure
we are able to absorb and mitigate layer
3 or layer 4
network or volumetric ddos attacks with
no impact on customer workloads
this mitigation happens automatically
far upstream from customer
infrastructure
across all types of global load
balancers including the https load
balancer ssl proxy and tcp
proxy users can then configure cloud
armor security policies to enforce
layer 7 filtering policies and waft
rules on a per
back-end service basis cloud armor
security policies can be used to enforce
ip or geo-based access controls mitigate
owa's top 10 risks
and otherwise filter traffic upstream of
an application based on layer 7
attributes
today we are proud to share that a rich
set of wav capabilities for cloud armor
is generally available
pre-configured waft rules can help
mitigate the oau's top 10 risks
we have ported over the mod security
core rule set
introducing rules to detect and block
sql injection
as well as cross-site scripting attacks
additionally
rules for local file inclusion remote
file inclusion and remote code execution
are available as beta
the rest of the core rule set is
targeted for release over the course of
this year
with geo-based rules customers can
enforce access controls based on the
source geography of each
ip to request mappings are sourced from
google's geo team
so you can be sure of its accuracy
we've also launched an extensible rules
language that allows users to configure
custom layer 7 filtering policies across
request headers request parameters or
cookies
finally cloud armor is now integrated
with the cloud security command center
with cloud armor findings being sent to
the cscc dashboard to alert defenders of
potential attacks against protected
applications or websites
we have recently greatly increased the
flexibility of a cloud armor deployment
to protect
an expanded set of customer
infrastructure on gcp
as well as in hybrid use cases located
on-prem or in other cloud providers
cloud armor now supports protecting
cloud cdn
origin servers by enforcing cloud armor
security policies
on dynamic requests as well as cache
misses destined for the cdn origin
server customer applications are often
complex
serving both cachable static content as
well as dynamic requests from the same
services
with cloud armor able to inspect and
filter requests destined to cdn origin
servers
users can now mitigate computationally
expensive cache busting attacks
as well as help protect dynamic portions
of websites and applications from
the os top 10 risks
enterprises often need to enforce a
consistent set of security controls to
their applications no matter where they
are deployed
whether they are migrating to gcp or
running in
permanently hybrid configurations we've
recently launched support for internet
network
endpoint groups that allow customers to
leverage all of google's edge
infrastructure
including our global load balancers
cloud cdn and cloud
armor to protect their website or
applications no matter where they are
hosted
now google can help protect your
applications whether from ddos attacks
or other common web attacks without
customers having to deploy their
infrastructure on gcp
finally gke ingress support for cloud
armor has reached
general availability gke users can help
protect their containerized workloads by
placing them behind google's global load
balancers
and configuring cloud armor security
policies for layer 7 filtering and wife
use cases
with that i'd like to hand it off to
tracy to discuss cloud firewalls
thank you email in the next section
we're going to be going through the
cloud
flowers first we'll give you a quick
introduction
about the vpc firewall rules then we're
going to talk about
two new modules that we recently brought
to market to strengthen our offerings
google cloud firewall has a different
architecture than the traditional
fireworks
in a sense it does not have a physical
box that you need to configure
and pipe your traffic through for
filtering instead
it is offered as a virtual firewall
service that is fully integrated
into our google sdn fabric the policy
enforcement
happens on the host for each individual
vm instances
compared with the traditional model this
type of architecture will give you a
higher scalability
and has no choke point it is a fully
scalable
and stateful firework that inspects both
ingress and egress traffic
users can also make use of the network
tag service account
to define the fine granular firewall
rules
and implement their micro segmentation
strategies
as we know the vpc firewall operates at
the vpc level
it allows users to define an independent
set of flower rules
for each individual vpc this gives you
the project owners a lot of independence
and
flexibility in controlling your forward
reset
and operate in such a dynamic cloud
environment
however it does present some challenges
for corporate security team in large
enterprises
this type of organization typically has
hundreds
sometimes even thousands of projects and
networks in their same organization
oftentimes they want to implement some
common draw
across all the networks and the projects
without the central control it's
typically very difficult to do so
also the project owner oftentimes do not
have in as
in depth of security knowledge as their
security team does
therefore they could make some mistakes
and misconfigure their viral rules
and then expose their workload at risk
how to maintain a dynamic and safe cloud
environment
and strike a dilated balance between
control and delegation has been a
constant battle
for those central securities
hierarchical firewall policies are
introduced precisely to address this
type of pinpoints
with hierarchical firewall policies
users can define and attach
firewall policies at a higher level of
the hierarchy
specifically organization and folder
nodes
where the centralized control can be
defined
and enforced
firewall policies is different from a
traditional flower rules
it is a container that can contain
multiple flower rules
in there it can be defined once and then
later attached
to different nodes in the hierarchy
also when you try to modify the reset
within a central policy you can actually
execute it in a batch mode
when firewall policies are attached to
different level of the node in the
resource hierarchy
they follow a very strict enforcement
sequence
from top to the bottom all traffic must
pass the org level security rules
before they be evaluated at the folder
level
and eventually at the vpc level this
type of model
made it impossible for project owners to
bypass
or overwrite security policies that are
set by the central team
they'll also make sure that any new
project and new networks
added to the organization can be
protected by those central policies
from day one
defining rules at the org and folder
level doesn't mean that
all those rules must apply to all
instances in the same way
user can actually use target service
account to designate certain instances
for selected rules for example a user
could define
a firewall sitting at the org level that
forbid all the ingress traffic and only
allow that equals traffic
for a selected set of proxy servers that
with certain service accounts associated
with it
another module that we recently brought
to the public beta
is called firewall insights this module
is introduced to help our customers
manage complex flower reset
in a large vpc environment
many enterprise customers face
challenges in maintaining
a clean and robust flower reset over
time
and face many challenges such as massive
volumes
a vpc can have hundreds or even
thousands of rules associated with it
over grounding is another issue but lack
of visibility into the
rule usage data it's typically very
difficult to find them out and eliminate
those type of risks
human error is another factor that could
introduce misconfigured flower rules
an outdated rules with ones are left
over by the previous project
never gets cleaned up
with firewall insights we introduce a
set of capabilities that hopefully will
help our customers better manage
those challenges first we introduce a
set of metrics
for firewall usage such as the head
count and last hit time
using this metrics user can easily find
those allow rules that are not used
and clean them up in order to tighten
the security boundary
during troubleshooting time users also
can make use of those shoes to know
precisely
which rules are being hit when certain
traffic pass through
they can also detect abnormal traffic
pattern by observing
sudden jump in their hit trend
all those metrics are exported to
stackdriver
where users could use them to create
custom dashboard
define user-defined alerts in order to
catch conditions they are interested in
our insights also brings a module that
automatically
scans the entire project for all the
flower roots and detect
shadow relationships a shadow rule is a
root that is overshadowed
by one or more rules sitting at a higher
priority
without machines help it's typically
very difficult
to find it out manually with forward
rule insights
we report centrally for all the
shadowing relationship in the a project
and we refresh that periodically so that
user could simply go through the report
examine each shadowing relationships and
eliminate them
as needed
next we're going to talk about the new
module that we recently brought to
market
called packet mirroring
so what is pac-mary and why do you need
it
as we know that to build a robust threat
detection program
we need the combination of the network's
threat detection system
combined with edr and c to give us the
critical visibility
that enables quick threat investigation
and response
and minimize the damage during an attack
network data is often considered a
ground truth
it provides a complete visibility of the
network activities
it's usually difficult to evade and
cannot be easily turned off
during an attack when an infected host
is trying to reach another host
the moment a packet leaves the host it
will leave the trace in your network
data
which will be captured therefore
it often considers a very reliable data
source for threat investigation
many of our enterprise customers are
already taking advantage of this set of
data
new set of tools to collect and analyze
those data
for their security purposes
we're moving to the public
they sometimes cannot get the same level
of visibility into the network traffic
however when they are moving more and
more workload
into the cloud the network starts become
very complex
therefore they demand the same level of
visibility
for the network traffic for performance
monitoring
and security control purposes
gcp packet mirroring is introduced
precisely to address
this type of need they help users
increase their confidence
in their cloud migration and ensure a
smooth transition
and give them ability to implement
advanced
and proactive security countries
gcp packing mirroring is now generally
available in
all regions for all vm instance types
it can help capture traffic from all
different directions
traffic between vm to vm between vm to
internet
also between vm to google services
when combined with intrusion detection
systems it can help users
easily detect abnormal traffic patterns
and capture
the emerging risk it can also help them
satisfy
the compliance requirement and also used
for application performance monitoring
and troubleshooting purposes
now let's take a look how the track
packing memory works
under the hood packing mirroring can be
enabled for both
gce vm instances as well as gke clusters
it happens at the instance level so
whenever the packet mirroring is enabled
it captures all the traffic both ingress
and egress
including the header and the payload
to configure a packet mirroring you need
both front-end and back-end policies
the front-end policy will define which
instance will be enabled for packet
mirroring
you can specify specific individual
instance
to be activated you can also specify a
group of instances by
specifying the subnet or using network
tags
the backend policies specify where the
collector
endpoint is a collector endpoint is an
internal load balancer that sits in
front of a group of
collector vms the collector vms usually
are running a set of
partner solutions such as the palato's
ids systems
when the policy is defined the packet
mirroring traffic will be piped
through the internal load balancer into
those collector vms
where the different system will consume
those traffic
to perform different type of
functionalities
we recommend that you use instant
templates and manage
instance group to manage these collector
vms
it will give you auto scaling and auto
heating capability
and help you meet traffic demand and
availability requirement
packet mirroring can be configured via
api and gcloud command
can also be triggered and enabled
through the cloud functions
while patent mirroring provides critical
data enables a set of
critical use cases it won't be the
complete solution without our ecosystem
partners support
therefore we have built an ecosystem
with vendors coming from network
security
and network monitoring domains so that
our customers
could make use of the tool that they are
familiar with
to consume on those patent marine
traffic
and buildage and solution to satisfy
their needs
to learn more about the network security
functionality that we just went over in
this
session here are a list of resources
including blogs
documentation live demo and some
other next sessions you want to refer to
thank you very much for joining the
session today we hope you enjoyed the
rest of the show